the United States just celebrated Earth
Day with a large outpouring of concern
about the environment a lot of people
demonstrating and talking about the
environment we're very fortunate on
alternative views today to have John
Milton with us if you haven't heard of
John Milton well you should have because
he is one of the originals talking about
the environment and doing something
about the environment all around the
world he's one of the founders of
Friends of the Earth he's written eight
or nine books about the the environment
as an ecologist he actually wrote the
first basic book on the environment
called the future environments in North
America and another one of his many
books was called the careless technology
the results of what happens when the
World Bank and some of those people go
in and have these different operations
and different constructions which
particularly in the third world John
also has set up ecological activist
coalition's around the world he set up
national parks all over the world and
well gosh if I continued on talking
about what he's done it cuts into the
time we have to talk with him so John
we're really pleased we're going to be
here a pleasure and that you flew in all
the way from Colorado to be with us what
we want to do is to have a general
overall survey of all the ecological
problems that face us and then talk
about what is being done what we can do
and whether it's too late or not and
also who is responsible for the
environmental problems which we have
right now well you're specialists in the
rain forest particular you've been all
over the Amazon and in many parts of the
world but is the rain forest destruction
really as bad as what they say if
anything I think it's a little worse
than what you generally hear in the
media and one of the things that
astounds me is that we're now
calculating that within the next 10
years most of the rain forests left in
Southeast Asia which had one of the most
diverse rain for us anywhere in the
world
it contains somewhere between 50 and 60
percent of the all the species that are
found in the tropics that that forest
will be virtually eliminated within the
next ten years and what is causing that
is that an aftermath of Vietnam and the
Indochina Wars our economic development
part of that is involved in the sense
that the the whole movement of
industrialization in that part of the
world began to happen at that time but
there's there's so many players now from
so many different countries that are
beginning to move into the into the
Southeast Asian picture that you want
the major players for example that's
become Japan and just as you both I'm
sure quite aware of the role of the
Japanese in causing the everything from
the killing of tuna but we're fishing in
Alaskan waters tremendous devastation in
terms of the ocean environment in the
same way they've been a major factor in
the destruction of the tropical forests
of Indonesia and Malaysia and very
recently began to move into Burma now
Burma is a country that because it's
been so closed off from the outside
world and because there's been a war
going on between those tribes in the
north and the government down in Rangoon
Rangoon in the South Burma has
effectively remain closed to development
interests from the outside the Japanese
just recently negotiated a contract to
go in there and do massive deforestation
of the teak forests and the rainforests
of Burma for the first time and that was
the last place we had in Southeast Asia
that we've helped at least in Burma
those great forests would be protected
and if there was a chance for the
the reforestation of many of the other
countries at least Burma would be a pool
at which the reforestation could occur
now even that is up in the air because
of this Japanese initiative now they say
that they and the multinational
corporations in the various countries
say that they want the raw materials or
they industrialized countries North to
use so this is why they're doing it and
they say that it's worth the price what
is the price of these raw materials no
destroying the rainforest well that's
the whole problem with the economic
system with that we've got there is
basically all of the environmental costs
are not factored in virtually all of
them are not factored in when it comes
to the way that the cost-benefit ratios
are calculated in classical economic
theory when you do a cost-benefit ratio
in general the air of the water the
genetic value of the genetic pool of
resources that that's involved all of
these kinds of things are have no value
whatsoever they're not factored in it in
any way another problem for the way in
which we've we work our economics with
the living web that is that by and large
the cost-benefit ratio tends to favor
particularly if you have a high discount
rate it tends to favor very rapid
consumption and utilization resources in
the near-term future to make a profit as
quickly as possible this allows you to
pay off the discount rate to pay off the
interest quickly to the banks yes and if
that is a higher rate than of course you
want to do it even faster this means
that you basically in a cost-benefit
ratio which balances the costs and the
benefits in most cases because the your
you're running to make that profit and
to pay back the banks or whatever the
loan institution may be
most of the costs most of the impacts
are very very long-term costs and yet
you may get the loss of an entire
ecosystem or devastating floods in the
in the Ganges could wipe out the homes
and the livelihood for millions of
people but in the near term you might
get two or three years of productive
agriculture up in the hills before
everything starts to wash away what
terms the cost-benefit ratio it makes
sense to go ahead and plant those two or
three years of crops make that profit
and forget about what happens 20 years
down the road it doesn't matter because
that's so far down the road in terms of
the cost-benefit ratio that it comes out
in the ratio is a very tiny little
figure it's not amazing and that's the
way our decision making is made in terms
of the environment we frequently read
about in here about Brazil and what is
happening there terrible destruction not
only the rainforest but of people in
their culture the vicious massacres of
the Indians native populations in
addition to this I've read some really
scary things that because this is the
play the enormous rainforests produced
the oxygen which we eventually which we
breathe as being recirculated around the
world it mean is there really possible
that the world could run out of oxygen
because of the depletion of these
rainforests it could certainly enter
into a major of a major contribution in
the depletion of the oxygen on the
planet the oceans also play a major role
in this but also in a rain and in the in
every way
rain in every way this could cause
perhaps gravitas droughts around the
world in a good example of this and
people don't generally realize this but
the the tropical zones are acting like a
huge weather generator if you go into
the into the Amazon basin it's amazing
because those rains start out in the
Atlantic Ocean and they start rolling
across the Amazon basin a great rolling
wave of weather and as it moves across
the Amazon basin and you have the
rainfall which then of course nurtures
the rainforest
the rain comes down and then
approximately 75 to 80 percent of that
rainfall is immediately that put
transpired back into the atmosphere only
something like 20% of it goes back into
the river systems and then much of that
actually gets pulled out by the roots
again and also we circulated so perhaps
only something like 10% of that that
moisture actually goes back out to the
Atlantic sly of the Amazon all the rest
of it moves in a tremendous rolling wave
of moisture and humidity that goes all
the way across amazon waters it and then
moves to the north in the south to water
Venezuela and down to in the case of to
the north - water Venezuelan to the
south - water the Argentine the Chilean
territory as it moves to the south it
waters in particular some of the very
fertile lands that we have down in in
northern Argentina in particular it is
virtually the major weather generator
for the entire breadbasket of that part
of South America which is probably the
most productive area in South America
with it was interesting when a series of
multinational agricultural corporations
moved into southern Brazil and Argentina
Chile they saw that there was very very
rich land in that part of the part of
the world they decided they wanted it so
they developed a scheme in collusion for
the Brazilian government to basically
buy out the settlers the people that had
farmed that land the small farmers that
had done a real good job for hundreds of
years and that really rich agricultural
land they worked at a deal with the
Brazilian government to build roads with
World Bank and a ID money from our
country and then provided very
attractive sending 160 plus hectare
pieces of land
in the Amazon rainforest not telling
anybody that that sells only
cultivatable for a few years and then it
becomes infertile God solely infertile
forever or can it be retrieve infertile
forever under conventional agriculture
thanks Tom
and not only that it often becomes hard
laterite and becomes a desert but that's
another story
the point is that the basically had a
forced exodus of millions of people from
this the zone to the south which then
settled the Amazon becomes the Amazon
deforested vast areas the multinationals
ended up with a good agricultural soil
in the South that was not subject to the
heavy leaching and loss of agricultural
nutrients and soil nutrients that you
find in in the tropics and the people
that used to live on that land it ended
up with soil which then produced for one
to three years dig quite well and then
suddenly they began to find that the
protein yields my dad then they found
that their overall yield just the amount
of biomass amount of agricultural
material that they can grow period began
to drop and then suddenly they found
they can hardly grow a thing because the
leaching of when you have an
agricultural system with its put into a
rainforest the original system there is
a very complex multi-tiered rainforest
that basically has many strata to the
forest and so you have high trees deep
root systems broad root systems and
layers underneath that with different
networks of roots stand into the soil
and enter an herbaceous layer with again
a whole nother network of roots when the
leaves fall because of the high
temperatures they break down very fast
and break down into soluble nutrients
high rainfall high temperature those
nutrients very quickly get leached out
of the soil and immediately picked up by
those root systems and recirculated back
up into the living system so most of the
fertility of the rainforest is literally
in the living organic system it's
amazing when you cut that forest
of course what the first thing that
happens is you go and you plant your
crops but it doesn't the the network of
roots only covers a very shallow area on
the surface plus there many areas where
there's no crop at all lots of spaces in
between so after a couple of years of
rainfall under those high temperatures
and high rainfall the nutrients start
getting leached deeper and deeper and
deeper and deeper meanwhile what's left
of the old roots of the old rain forest
system begin to go and die off soon
there's nothing left to capture those
nutrients and they're lost forever
eventually they go down into the earth
then if you continue with your insanity
your agricultural insanity what often
happens is that that soil becomes a
rock-hard laterite which means that it
binds and becomes literally as hard as
rock you have to take a pickaxe to it to
break it up so you can't then refine a
chef in any way then it's very difficult
for roots to to get anything down into
it it becomes baked and this is already
happening as a result of the destruction
exactly over what diamond expanse
oh is it massive yes last year I
remember the reports we had from the
rainforests or something like they were
reporting between fifty and a hundred
thousand fires burning major fires
printing just in the Amazon alone as as
the Amazon was being cleared and the
paradox and then the tragedy of this is
that those people who were the victims
the people that are being brought into
that territory the whole motivation was
to provoke to give the land away cheap
to these multinational corporations that
voted out for the south where you don't
have those high temperatures and you
don't have that heavy leaching because
of the high rainfall and high high
temperatures John Young would like our
own Midwest you'd mentioned the
devastating effect this would have on
all of Latin America if the rainforest
dries up because the weather from that
goes as you said throughout the
continent what effect does it have in a
more global dimension in terms of global
warming trends or
then weather patterns that go to the
United States Europe and the entire
world is it a big impact on that as well
yeah definitely because basically in the
same way that we were talking about that
rolling mass of moisture that moves
across the Amazon two things other
things happen when you can destroy the
rainforest you destroy the entire winter
weather generator for the countries to
the north and the countries to the south
which means you basically eliminate the
rainfall base for Argentina Chile
Venezuela Ecuador and so on it doesn't
just affect the Amazon basin it affects
that entire area in addition just like
an air conditioning unit when you remove
all the vegetation all the transpiration
and evaporation that's occurring and you
leave behind a kind of hot desertic kind
of environment you completely change the
rate at which the upwelling occurs of
hot air along the equatorial belt and
the related sub-material belts because
they're being deforested too that means
that the whole weather generation system
which basically depends upon a
particular rates of you of the lifting
of hot air up into thee from the equator
its descent again further north all of
that has a very powerful effect on wind
patterns on rainfall distribution and so
on all that gets totally disrupted all
of our crops are entirely in all over
the world are entirely dependent upon a
stable weather distribution pattern if
you change that suddenly the trees can't
live because they're not getting enough
rainfall or it starts getting too hot
which you cold you basically introduce
massive destabilization into global
environments and totally unpredictable
ways it's much more serious than just
the loss of oxygen which is serious but
the main saying that I feel is the issue
is the total destabilization of world
clinic and when you think that just to
loss in our Midwest let's say if we have
an average reduction of five inches of
rainfall a year that's it you've got a
southwestern desert back to the Dust
Bowl yeah and we're at the same time
we're running out
the we've already mined all the water
out of the Oklahoma aquifer in the in
the high plains so there's no fossil
water to fall back on because we've
already wasted that and we're poisoning
what little is left with fertilizers and
artificial fertilizers so we're left
with a situation where I can see that
directly impacting our American
breadbasket and already it's happening
it's already happening well you see
these documentaries are news stories
about how the water is disappearing from
out west because the big farms are using
it up this is just another one of the
ecological disasters and the aquifer
poisoning at the same time even if we
had didn't have the problem with the e
with rainforest destruction what effect
would that have on the United States of
the aquifer poisoning and the water
depletion from overuse well basically
this country under the wise and careful
custodianship of the Native American
peoples maintained a tremendously rich
series of organic systems ecosystems and
resources which amazed me when you look
at the other parts of the world like
China most of Asia relate for that
matter answered made the universe
tremendously rich organic diversity had
been maintained here under the under the
custodianship Native Americans how did
that work what did they do to preserve
these systems well you know there's one
value produced I mean there's one value
there that is interesting and we were
talking earlier about the cost-benefit
ratio and how basically the cost-benefit
ratio says if he doesn't pay back within
two five years it's no good doesn't
matter what the cost is further down the
road that's just a tiny little thing
the only thing we care about is what we
get back in two to five years and that's
the fundamental value of this culture
that we've got that's the basic problem
right there and what did the Native
Americans do differently well the Native
Americans said we will not make any
changes unless we look ahead seven
generations minimum Wow and we can see
that it will be good for that seventh
generation
if it would be good for that seventh
generation and for all the other living
beings of the earth that are who our
brothers and our sisters and our mothers
and our fathers and our grandfathers and
our grandmothers and our cousins then I
change is good and beneficial I will go
ahead
that was their basic economics and what
did they do to preserve the systems in
terms of their technologies that is just
that they didn't pollute them they
didn't they were cautious as to what
waste went in them where did they
actually cultivate the aquifers digging
irrigation ditches or whatever there was
some but the basic Native American ethic
said that you will respect the the skin
of mother earth mother earth is a living
organism and to go deep into mother
earth and to and to take out her
lifeblood through by trying to mine the
water or mind the deep minerals is is
like doing surgery on your mother when
she doesn't need it when she's perfectly
healthy would you go and take your
mother and and cut her open and start
taking her organs out uh-huh
so that's what's basically there you and
now we might look at that and say well
this is ridiculous
but I mean take a look at what we've
done we've mined out the Ogallala
Aquifer it's it's just about dead
there's no where is that [ __ ] here well
basically runs from near the Canadian
border and it runs along the whole
Plains short grass prairie on into the
tall grass prairie country from up in
the Montana country then through Kansas
run into into Texas and it's the major
aquifer for the western plains district
of the Rocky Mountain region or just
going up to the Rockies and it was the
main water resource that we had other
than the free-flowing River systems
themselves what we have done has come up
with in
through our technology and incredibly
wasteful system of mining that water and
then spreading that water out on the
land no concept of even the most
fundamental things like a drip
irrigation system which very carefully
meters are just a little bit of water at
a time the minimum you need to keep the
agriculture working instead of just
massive utilization of the water no cost
placed upon the fact that it's a fossil
water that's not going to last forever
so basically what we have done is to
take the gift of Mother Earth there
we've mined out the fundamental organ
system you might say the Monroes you
mean stuff like iron and coal and same
thing the same thing isn't water we've
taken the the copper and we've taken the
the iron we've taken all the minerals
and just ripped it out of the earth what
happens if there's a breakdown in
culture following a major global
catastrophe if there is a either some
sort of catastrophic war or some major
breakdown within the overall structure
we do not have concentrated sources of
minerals anymore it takes a lot of
energy to extract those minerals
concentrate them bring them back
together again but the only source over
some dumps
and it's an interesting there I think
with Harrison Brown that came up with
the thesis that the decline of
civilization may be due to the fact that
we've already wasted all of the
concentrated mineral resources of the
planet if there's ever a major
perturbation and breakdown of the Organa
of the basic culture of the planet human
culture will never be able to come in
constantly concentrate all those mineral
resources to achieve any level of
technology in automotive technology it's
an interesting idea well there's another
thing that this happened and that is
soil depletion not only through erosion
but through chemical fertilizers not to
mention cut and burn tactics in
third-world what's the status of our
soil of course it gets blown away during
dust storms - what we talk about the
water without soil
you know well I should also say just
finishing on the water the fell excuse
me in the case of our Iguala we
basically it's almost gone we just have
a few years left now people are
frantically trying to grab water from
from the Rocky Mountains la is just
sucking the Colorado dry the Texas and
Colorado are both trying to go into the
San Luis Valley in southern Colorado and
steal the water away from all of the
farmers of that region that have lived
there for for hundreds of years and take
that water and pipe it into Texas in
Colorado in order to bail them out for a
few more years and there's some interest
groups that are ten make several billion
dollars of that project but it will
devastate the farming community southern
Colorado which is already a poor it's
been a community right you know for the
most part in a poor angle it'll poorest
panic community wonderful people but
there's not lots of money and the only
thing I depend upon is their agriculture
that's what they live on you take that
water you destroy their livelihood
totally and we're talking now about
destroying the few self-aligned I was
angry cultural systems we have left
siphoning off water for the cities and
for the very wasteful agribusiness
farming operations which is a tremendous
amount of water
much more than it's necessary at least
the small farmers by and large tend to
be much more conservative about the use
the corner and the same thing the soil
now the loss of the water resource is
happening everywhere it's most apparent
in the southwest because there the water
resources are very scarce and critical
and so we're coming up to that fine edge
much earlier but it's of course
happening a major issue in California
and becoming a major issue even in the
well water a relatively low water East
Coast simply because we've polluted so
much and we've wasted so much even in a
incredibly well water period in fact
let's talk about pollution for a minute
before getting into the soil in 1962 I
think it was rachel carson's wrote her
book Silent Spring that was one of the
first dramatic documentation of the
poisoning of our rivers our lakes and
the sea through chemical and other
industrial pollutants what has the
situation been with pollutant since then
we didn't learn a lesson early on in the
early sixties you also were writing
about this topic at that time and
despite the scientific knowledge and
awareness that tremendous amount the
pesticides and chemical and industrial
pollutants were destroying what was left
of our water these ways continue did
they not absolutely and what is the
magnitude of this today now 30 years or
so after I was just thinking while you
were talking about part of the year I
lived down in Baja California
conducting wilderness solos which I
believe to be a very powerful form of
environmental education and sort of an
opening up to a new kind of philosophy
that sees the the earth as an organic
living being we're directly without any
interpretation just a direct experience
of that but at the end of my work period
down there this year I had those in this
paradoxical situation I was working for
a group called the Conservation
Foundation back in the 60s and we gave
Rachel Carson the first grants to write
that block I say
spring and supported her work in the
back in the year in those days and I
suddenly found myself being subjected
with ten broad-spectrum applications of
malathion in the little agricultural
waste as I lived there in toto Santos
this was about four weeks ago my
partner's down there wonderful when
women from Texas another wonderful woman
from from that area myself had to
evacuate and was that when they were
spraying for the flying for the mid
flight see the net flies to mallet flies
bad stuff it's very benefi it's
teratogenic which means it causes
genetic mutations it's how it causes
many different forms of cancer and it
destroys the entire organic base of the
natural self-regulating control system
for pests the problems were too damn
greedy in most Native American cultures
another ethic was you give something to
nature everything in nature needs to be
taken care of all beings have equal
value including the insects so you offer
a part of your crop goes to to all these
different beings it's just the way of
nature you don't try to take it all you
know it's like sitting in a family table
and mom and dad take you know the whole
meal we don't treat our families that
way why should we treat nature that way
it doesn't make sense particularly in an
organic system it's totally
interconnected so basically that's what
we're trying to do with our contemporary
agricultural systems our whole approach
to the earth and it's into the resources
I mean they're not really resources
they're basically our family and down
there that same sort of greed took over
we banned a lot of that stuff here in
the States like DDT a lotta that's
getting exported into the Latin American
countries and into Asia and I mean
you're getting places that are having 50
to 60 and up to a hundred applications
of pesticide in a year
and coming back to us and food that we
import things right we imported all this
stuff too but on the malathion issue the
the paradox is that we already have the
techniques and the approaches we know
that if you sterile second sex
attractants you can kind of trap the
fruit flies in two traps which then move
the the fruit fly you can simply do
nothing and the natural wasp population
will build up and wipe out the mint
flower bring it down to a low level you
don't have to do a thing nature will do
it or if you want to speed it up a
little bit you can use some of these
newer techniques like the release of
sterile nails when you swamp the
population with the sterile male fruit
fly and basically that brings the
population down very radically of the
fruit fly and I guess that was done here
in Texas for the screwworm fly very
successfully doesn't affect any other
species redeye screwworm fly in the sea
in the case of the sterile males but in
any case the point being that we have
many very biological control all terms
we are not using these things and and
we're certainly not trusting the basic
inherent natural controls of nature
yourself and what is the extent of
pollution Sensei Rachel Carson's book in
the 60s is the percentage extent growing
dramatically or is it pretty much the
same or how would you rate it globally
in let's say in the u.s. in summer is
it's dropped and in other is it's
increased we have been able to eliminate
some basic pollutants of air water like
lead using some of the PCBs dropped
however some of the nitrogen based
pollutants have increased I'd say that
we probably have a greater problem of
fertilizer contamination of the soil
and organic contamination of the
groundwater systems we had and 10 years
ago 20 years ago by far on a global
basis I'd say were much worse off
many of the toxic chemicals that we
produce here in the United States as
we've developed more environmental
consciousness here we have exported
these chemicals through Dow and the
other two chemical companies we've
exported these these things into other
parts of the world and they still want
to make their profits and they do so
they sell them to countries that don't
really know what the hell's going on or
don't care they have governments that do
not care so ironic also you know this
also relates to smog and the stuff we
breathe and two things which we eat
which have all these chemical additives
and are as a result of the fertilizers
chemical fertilizers then you add on top
of this the fact that the tobacco
industry gets export subsidies to sell
cigarettes overseas and they're forcing
cigarettes on a lot of countries that
don't want them so that the the internal
ecology is being fouled as well as the
external environment of the of the world
what about the soil now we've talked
about the water being bad chemical
fertilizers being bad we've heard for
years about erosion and planting certain
crops which destroy the richness of the
soil what's the status of it a few years
back I guess it was around 78 78 79 80
oh I took a a job I was was working as a
professor of ecology and regional
environment
so the University of Colorado College
and central versus our University of
Illinois facility in central Illinois
and took a very deep look at what was
happening to the soil of our our
American Midwest which is really our
basic breadbasket these are the soils we
really depend put in Illinois in Iowa
and places like that
what astounded me was that we were given
a birthright in terms of our tendency of
this continent this Turtle Island the
Native Americans call it and Turtle
Island Islands the name North America
because on one hand it kind of looks
like a journal if you look at the
continent as a whole but also because
the Native Americans saw saw this
incredible continent is riding on the
back of a great cosmic turtle
whereas traveling through through the
universe and it was an interesting the
way it's their view of data I think a
very clear view of things like
continental drift a long time ago they
had different analogies for all but very
perceptive in any case when I went to
Illinois I was amazed that area which
used to have 36 inches prime topsoil
jewel is what that is 36 inches of
topsoil
when you talk about wealth Gold is
nothing compared to that
we took that 36 inches and in less than
100 years we brought it down to 10 to 18
inches we wasted between 1/2 and 2/3 and
how does that happen how do you deplete
or waste the soil in that way what you
do is you introduce a lot of mechanized
agriculture util a great deal you till
in such a way that you leave the soil
exposed we used to have a mixed
agricultural system in this country
small farming and agriculture so they
tended to be a broad scale utilization
of many different kinds of crops and you
had animals also as part of the
agricultural system as well as the crops
with that you tended to have recycling
of organic manures which helped soil
structure and also protected it crop
rotation give the crop rotation you had
many techniques in the old days which
made a lot of sense many of those
techniques were picked up from the
Native Americans the Native Americans
were doing a lot of really good thing we
should have learned a lot more things in
the Native Americans when we first came
here we had closed minds linear we were
not looking at the totality we were not
taking a holistic view we just looked at
ok we want this and we're going to get
it this way real greedy productive
outputs and ratio is just trying to
produce more in a shorter time also a
technological hubris thinking that big
technology is going to produce more and
better
just like big assembly lines in
factories produce more cars or more
steel likewise big farm mechanized farm
equipment is going to produce more goods
or more food but it's going to actually
destroy and deplete the soil and the
nutrients through then what happened
with in the case of the Midwestern soil
is that was definitely part of the
picture but and on top of that we phased
out the mixed agricultural system when
you had mixed agriculture it meant to
basically had to work there year-round
which means you could fine-tune the
agricultural cycle to the time of the
year knows you could plow just before
you plant it or shortly before
planet with the arising of eliminating
animals as part of your crop ecosystem
then a windfall cane well to save some
time in the spring since you had your
your tractor out there anyway you went
ahead and ploughed and you had a cover
crop and you plaid that under and then
you just let the soil I bear until it's
time for spring planting that meant that
the soil laid out there under the winter
rains and all the wind erosion for say
three to four months out of the year
that one simple change led to most of
the solar erosion yeah loss of our
heritage and why was that it was because
people wanted to take a vacation and go
to Florida
well what about agribusiness so they're
there they're a year-round operation
right they to tend since they can't grow
in many of these areas in the winter
because it's more efficient from a pure
business standpoint to get that edge as
close as possible if you do your plowing
and fall after you've got the last
possible crop in and then you do your
you do your plowing and then you get
that crop in as quickly as possible in
the spring as soon as you can get it in
there if you and you can do that if
you've already planted it back in the
fall same thing agribusiness is right in
there with everybody else
what about use of chemical fertilizers
what that do to the soil when you
introduce chemical agriculture the basic
problem is that the particularly a lot
of the nitrogen based chemical
fertilizers tend to create the very
blocky hard soil structure it becomes
difficult for the soil to hold water and
to maintain a structure that is relative
fairly friable and easy for plant root
systems to work with and over time it
actually can make it increasingly
difficult to plow even it's not unlike
what we were talking about with the
tropical laterites in some ways the
other thing that happens is that you
over time begin to make it more and more
difficult for
other kinds of nutrients to be up taken
by the root systems they can tend to get
trapped in the soil itself there are
many many different things that happen
we need to introduce chemical
fertilizers a major impact is that many
of the much of the excess of the
nitrogen and phosphorus that we apply to
cells washes off goes into the streams
and becomes a major source of chemical
pollution which basically wipes out the
the flora and fauna of the streams and
is another major source of organic
pollution of our rivers people don't
again don't recognize this either but
the thing I was going to say about the
breadbasket is that this breadbasket
we're down from let's say thirty six
inches to perhaps an average of ten
inches in a hundred years
hey soil yeah I mean that's let's say
two-thirds I'll say well at current
rates we're talking about wiping up the
agricultural foundation of our economy
within I'd say 20 between 25 and 50
years depending on how we manage it may
be basically a desert than our
breadbasket will be and I'm talking
about just through erosion and think
about it I just did I go ahead I'll be
dead by then you don't hear this being
talked about in the media very much I
mean your show is one of the few I've
ever been asked to even mention the
subject we're into trendy things I mean
I birthed a is an important initiative
don't get me wrong but and it's very
important to do things like recycling
but we are ignoring the fundamental core
ecosystem issues
what is it particularly that's polluting
the air what's causing a zone pollution
and smog and air pollution and global
warming trends obviously the air is part
of this ecosystem that's under assault
just like the slough in the water gosh
everything totally if you think about it
we live in such a highly technological
and industrial system that we're
becoming increasingly depend
upon our no synthetic cheers just look
what we're wearing yeah I try to wear
natural Cotton's as much as possible and
I'm wearing shoes made of cork but I
still have a little rubber that's partly
synthetic cotton socks if we just
analyze ourselves and start looking at
what we're using what we walk around
with this is organic in a sense this is
natural this Peter caisson it's quite
astounding and we write from our
clothing line on out into our
environment we're increasingly living
within a cultural ecosystem that sucks
resources out of the natural ecosystem
can calls it natural resources converts
it into stuff that we place value upon
and in the process of all the
transformations that occur particularly
when we shift into things like synthetic
plastics and many of them highly they're
all the different or official kinds of
chemicals that we've created it's
astounding there's so many pollutants in
the atmosphere at this point that I
don't think we even have a book the
tiniest clue of what each one of those
chemicals is doing when you when you
take a look at the windblown fertilizers
the pesticides all the traces poisons in
the atmosphere from all the different
kinds of chemical plants and different
kinds of processing plants and you take
a look at the then you look at the gross
ozone release from the automobiles and
the nitrogen and sulfur gas and releases
might have lived in the area in southern
Arizona that was being impacted with
some of the heaviest so2 pollution in in
the world from the copper smelter it's
built by Phelps dodge down there so2
being it's a sulfuric acid okay and for
about seven years my friends who were
asthmatic so know what several of them
died babies were being born with in
horrible condition and people were
walking around coughing wheezing phlegm
coming out of the lungs every day of
their life it took myself and two others
decided enough and we had a series of
strategy session sessions in the early
we constructed a campaign to basically
turn this around close that smelter den
or list the three smelters involved and
we then kicked off a campaign that drew
tremendous local support groups we had a
group called gasp and then it caught on
a little more get more attention from a
few national organizations that joined
in and helped and eventually we actually
closed the smelter I think it was two
years ago we closed the smelter down but
we had to have many very direct actions
in front of that smelter which is right
on the Mexican border route 666 dead
ends and that's milker which the
Christians will appreciate that that's
we basically had a series of what we
call die ends because at that time the
EPA was except that it was acceptable to
have cept or a risk to have 128 129
deaths in the immediate area of that
year or to know it was okay we shouldn't
really put too much pressure on filming
on so we had a Dian where we went down
and we had hundred and twenty-eight
people die in front of the smelter and
just to publicize that attitude that
value not to mention the fact that that
smelter was the source of virtually all
of the earth the major source of s rain
for the entire Rocky Mountain region
that meant that the Rocky Mountain
region only had a few years to go before
the lakes and the forests began to die
in the same way that the forests and the
lakes of the Appalachians have already
died okay that's what I know so that was
a unique opportunity for us to actually
go in and take an action and to do to
take an action in a peaceful way but
basically a direct action which would
hopefully get some results and it
actually did manage to turn things
around there's a lot that people can do
if they're willing to be good ecological
warriors with compassion once they're
fighting the same thing now with nuclear
plants that not even to mention the
nuclear weapons that have been set off a
nuclear bomb testing that is has
occurred in the air in the past and they
on the ground still but now they're
finding that the death rates and other
health problems have skyrocketed in just
within the areas of nuclear plants
similar to what you're talking about but
you can't see it and it's difficult to
measure so they don't do anything about
that
well the nuclear level is such a it's
such that represents such a level of
insanity I can I heart I find it almost
impossible to conceive of that level
full of demonic force being consciously
brought into the planet and that means
nuclear energy as well as nuclear
weapons yes both of them have the same
he struggles with nuclear energy is a
total - fraud fraud right because
basically every xi is no friend of mine
did one of the best analyses of this
process of anybody that I know
he runs the Institute in the Rocky
Mountains now for resource analysis and
excellent group in any case Emery
pointed out a number of years ago after
doing some very careful research that
the fundamental reason for building the
nuclear nuclear power plants for
peacetime use was to actually breathe
plutonium they can then be used for
right missiles and this was the main
purpose and that all of the talk about
low cost electrical usage was farce now
the other thing that we did nobody has
taken into account with these nuclear
plants I mean they don't work they work
for a few years and then something
generally will go wrong closes it down
they're very inefficient they're costly
to build in the very inefficient
the cost of decommissioning a nuclear
power plant has rarely been taken into
account and the commissioning costs we
know estimate on the average will run at
least two to three times more than the
cost of building plant cash they say
nobody has thought about those costs in
terms of what we're adding on to our
future generations you know what they
will have to pay it's making profit
today and then leaving that consequences
for tomorrow saying the federal deficits
another example of this mentality yes
and if if this is the case I mean no
well it's it's it's it's awesome because
we're talking about heading ending on
the cost here that is going to be
incredibly massive before for the future
on top of all of the other burdens that
are that we're passing along and then we
have on top of that things like
Chernobyl which which happen and those
kinds of things are going to happen
increasingly if we shift towards nuclear
I read recently that the cost of
cleaning up Chernobyl will be in excess
of 300 billion dollars that is the as I
recall about the size of our entire
military budget let's come true that's
just to clean up one nuclear power plant
catastrophe 300 billion dollars and and
people talk about peacetime peaceful use
of nuclear energy as a wonderful
alternative to fossil fuels and various
other things the thing is that when
Reagan came into power there was a man
named Dennis Hayes
close friend of mine who is working for
solar energy research institute and
Colorado he was building is that now
will the actually
the chairperson for Earth Day
interestingly enough Denis came out to
visit and give a talk in Illinois just
after the Reagan administration came in
and Dennis I saw Dennis at the airport
he looked kind of pale I've heard he had
our time as to what was wrong he said
well I've been fired and I said well
what's going on and he said well the
Reagan administration is going to
dismantle and basically put out a
business except for a little bit
research all solar energy initiatives in
this country and he's going to put in
place atomic and nuclear energy honest
that man Ronald Reagan our great
president put us behind on environmental
initiatives that we could have really
put us ahead we could have gone ahead
and prepared ourselves for an entry into
the only kind of energy system that
makes sense which is renewable energy
source all the plants do it they depend
on the Sun we depend on it in almost
every way if we think about a little bit
Reagan put us behind it at least a
decade during a period when all the
curves the crisis curves flowing out the
Fed rate and I'm not sure we'll ever get
past that period that he put us behind
the ignorance the vast ignorance of that
period people do not realize but it will
come home to wrist and unfortunately in
the near future the only way to go is a
good strong renewable energy resource
program which depends on things like
solar wind small mini hydro plants and a
variety of other sources that basically
work with the energy of the earth and
the energy of the Sun and can i generate
enough to keep up a sustainable sonnet
of love insurance he's John we've talked
about these various separate different
things that are ecological disasters and
big problems we didn't even mentioning
mentioned things like TV monitors and
video display terminals which they start
kids in kindergarten in first grade they
radiate and can hurt hurt people I think
they're kind of like many nuclear plants
in that sense what
well the first question is what can you
tell us about that and the second
question is all these things we've
talked about they certainly must have
some type of interacting synergistic
relationship which to make all these
worse right well the electromagnetic
pollution is the subject to interest me
very much because it has been relatively
ignored I think we began to become aware
of it when there was a lot of the the
use of it as a military weapon I guess
when the Russians were zapping the
American Embassy in Moscow but in point
of fact electromagnetic pollution is has
become a major source of imbalance of
the human body and in the mind the
emotions in almost every American city
it's interesting that direct-current
tends to be a much smoother kind of
electrical current than alternating
current alternating current literally
introduces jerky vibration
into the human body and it lives near
those fields and they're constantly
going like this and pretty soon you
start literally none at a very subtle
level doing that too now if you live
near high tension power lines high
tension is probably a good word for it
and you add on to that all the different
kinds of radio and television and all
the different kinds of waves which are
constantly bombarding us my feeling is
that we are it's having a major effect
on the health of the energy body we're
just beginning to realize from studies
in Chinese medicine which again the
American medical community would like to
ignore but unfortunately acupuncture is
so we'll proven by now that they had to
acknowledge that in fact there are
energy flows I'm having a treatment
right now with an acupuncture a couple
of acupuncture points for a bad tooth
maybe when they began to see the pain
control was so effective with
Juran I began to see that certain kinds
of Qi Gong and Tai Chi movement
exercises were so beneficial in the
hospital center of China they began to
say okay there is something here and
maybe there is something to this theory
of energy flow through the meridians of
the body the basic thing about
electromagnetic pollution is that it
completely imbalances the natural energy
flow through those meridians of the body
and I'm convinced it's one of the
sources of dues about disease I mean
disease is basically this ease lack of
full bodily and mental and emotional
ease and it seems like we've done
everything possible to move out of that
state and maybe not intentionally but if
you think about it the human organism
evolved over millions of years in nature
surrounded by natural organic materials
leading fairly natural food like nuts
and seeds and tubers and leafy shoots
and things of that kind
probably some things from Jesus see and
then oh we were living with relatively
organic materials on our bodies with
clean air and and environments which
were very close to nature that was that
was the way it was for millions of years
we lived in relatively small extended
family environments and tribal
environments and we had people
occasionally going out for periods of
solo time to reconnect deeply with with
nature and then would come back into the
family we're so far from that now I mean
everything in our life is totally
artificial and the urban industrial era
has only been with us for what several
hundred years if you were to take a look
at the tendency of human beings on the
planet how long we've been here and that
was an hour on a clock we're this urban
industrial culture is just a tiny tiny
fraction of a second for midnight and
[Music]
and we're using this we assume that this
is the standard as if you know this is
the way it always was and this is the
way it always will be
that's a vast illusion and this culture
is not sustainable it will not last it
is on the way out the question is what
will replace it what will replace it
depends entirely on the actions that we
take now and in the future and it's one
of the reasons that the ecological
awakening is so important but the main
point I wanted to make is that our whole
being our emotions our body our mind
evolved rikuo volved with the organic
system and fabric of life of the planet
over millions of years in a few hundred
years we replaced that with a totally
synthetic and artificial existence how
can we possibly expect to be healthy
emotionally mentally or physically it is
no accident we're having diseases that
are breakdowns of the immune system
breakdowns of the basic cellular system
like cancer cancer is behaving like we
are it is simply chromatic control it's
the reflection in our bodies of what
we've become in relation to the planet
so if you think about it cancer is a
cell that is is does not regulate itself
it grows without any control the cancer
spreads it kills you it kills the body
in a similar way it has created as only
wants to consume the resources of the
rest of the organs of the body the organ
systems of the body it doesn't care it
just wants to grow without limit the
human being and it kills it kills it
kills us
the human being is growing on the planet
with no regard for all the organ systems
of the planet for mother Gaia it grows
without any limit it will grow until the
planet is dead
that is how we were actually behaving so
of course our bodies are now reflecting
cancer which is simply the natural
microcosmic reflection of
behavior the behavior that we're
inflicting upon mother earth or self so
to talk about synergy which was your
other question synergy by the way means
synergy is where you look at the total
netis of the interrelated effects of all
the different actions and reactions of
something and you may have let's say a
cumulative effect of we have in our
environment stresses coming in from
driving to work four hours a day and
beating on the steering wheel I was
talking to somebody about it was a
mechanic recently working with air
conditioning units and I saw him down in
Baja driving a Toyota and he said I said
what do you what were you doing up there
in California said well I I used to
repair air conditioning units in San
Diego and I liked it I said well why'd
you leave and he said well too many
years of driving on those freeways to
get bigger and bigger and more and more
stressed out I began to see people
literally going crazy on the road there
pounding you hear about the you know the
shooting [ __ ] what you're doing here
about is the thousands if not millions
of people screaming pounding on the
steering wheel or trying to bottle it
all up inside you don't hear so much
about that but that's what's going on
and you take that kind of stress you add
it to chemical pollutants you add it to
pesticides you add it to poor nutrition
and so on and the cumulative impact of
all that did you take in together is
synergistic if that means that when you
add one kind of toxin to another toxin
you get something usually that's far
more toxic than just one thing alone
most of our tests of the effect of
environmental pollutants or poisons of
one kind or another
Veta physiological stress or a literal
toxin
Thaksin is single factor analysis it
means that we don't look at the total
system and the total range of impacts
that are working on that system
simultaneously as they actually do in
nature in the actual world and through
the single factor analysis the EPA and
the rarest engines of government set
their standards for what's allowable in
terms of a pollutant for example there's
no interest in finding out what the sum
total of all that is if you took each
one of those impacts and and took a look
at the the impact of that on a human
being or an animal another kind of
animal I should say there's no question
that the cumulative impact would be far
greater than the single factor alone far
far greater a quantum shift greater and
we are not measuring for that nowhere in
government nowhere in science and yet
that's what's actually going on it's
amazing and now we want to talk about
what we can do what we must do in order
to group to prevent all these
catastrophes or less maybe heck maybe
Homo Sapien and worth it maybe we should
just you know shuffle off and give
things back to the to the good animals
of the world but anyway for going to do
something I guess we have to look at
Earth in a different way than we have in
the past and do you have that some other
people are doing this aren't you yeah I
think simile hopeful signs one of the
things that is particularly interested
me is the growth on the one hand of a
different philosophical view of what the
human being is and what the earth is and
the relationship of the human being to
the earth and also to the the matter in
the mother might air
the earth that we live with right here
in our bodies and there's a new of a
friend of mine Jim Lovelock has been
working for some years with a close
friend of his they came up with a theory
entitled the Gaia hypothesis several
years ago Gaia yes got expelled because
GA ia ji and basically this hypothesis
says that the earth is behaving like a
living organism and that may be sound a
little radical to those people that tell
our thinking about the earth is
basically just a bunch of stuff out
there you know a resource system that
you go and exploit and you pull stuff in
and you transform it into your BMW but
in point of view the earth has been here
much longer than we have it gave birth
to us in our species we've been here
maybe a million a couple million years
the earth has been here for billions and
billions of years and we don't really
know what the earth is it's a great
mystery we have something that we call
science but just imagine if if our whole
culture were a little cluster of cells
somewhere down on the left side of the
liver and that little cluster of cells
was trying to figure out what is this
what is this that I'm living within hmmm
it would be very difficult it would
probably be give particularly if it was
a series of cancer cells living on the
liver and starting to grow it would
probably view the rest of this body that
it was living within and on as simply a
rather convenient kind of mass of
organic stuff do utilize an extract
stuff from for its own growth and then
it would prove put together a
philosophical system that would you know
fit that view of unlimited growth
of an egocentric view of the species
now the eco-centric view eco-centric
guru basically says that well the earth
is a living organism it's alive just as
the human body is it's a vast body of
which we are part we're cells in that
great body all the living beings in that
body have different roles and
interrelationships that play a part
within the that great body of Mother
Earth some of them are acting like
different tissues some of them are
acting like different organs of the body
like the tropical rainforests and the
oceans are producing the oxygen and
helping to uptake some of the carbon
dioxide and maintain the atmospheric
cycles and the rainfall cycles and so on
and so forth Oh
basically the self-regulating behavior
of the whole planet so that all life is
supported is what AIA is all about and
what the Gaia hypothesis is all about
the original idea came about when they
discovered that the oxygen levels of the
planet were exactly maintained at that
level that if went any higher the if you
had a forest fire you could not put it
out they were just everything would
combust if it went down below that level
at a time we wouldn't have enough to
respire properly and somehow over
millennia it has maintained a perfect
oxygen equilibrium for the perfect
maintenance of all the different species
of the earth and when Lovelock took a
look at all the different possible
mechanisms for this he came to the
conclusion that the only way the earth
can do this is through a basic
self-regulation system that would be
just like how the human body self
release regulates itself to maintain the
equilibrium and the homeostasis and
stability of the body as well as the
growth
of the overall bunny oh this is a
revolutionary idea of course then they
went ahead and began to examine that
principle that hypothesis in light of
evolutionary theory and they found the
same thing began to hold true again and
again they found principle examples
within evolutionary biology that that
basically pointed the same truth that
the earth was behaving like a living
organism so suddenly we're beginning to
move into a view that says is saying
something very different than what our
forefathers said that the earth is just
dead thing but interestingly enough with
a few species living on it to happen to
be you know to survival of the fittest
and all that kind of craziness doing
what they're doing
we've never really given much attention
to the interconnectedness of life the
symbiotic cooperative nature of life but
of course it probably began in a fairly
small way and then somehow managed to
grow out into this rather amazingly
interconnected and mutually supporting
system and cooperation probably has been
about at least 90% of that process then
there's competition in there too but
competition is just the flipside of
cooperation the two are completely
intertwined just like the Enna's is a
part of the young and the young is a
part of the end so in a sense I think
for the first time we're beginning to
look at life as a and of the earth
itself as a guest
organic being whose intelligence we
can't there's no way to even begin to
you and speak of that because it's
beyond us it's beyond us to know what
that is or isn't but what we can say is
that the a of the living process of the
earth the flow of you might say of the
life force through the organ systems and
the tissues of the planet are definitely
behaving just like a body of course now
the earth evolved itself how does this
hypothesis
into the various stages of the earth the
Aleutian knew the earth that's a very
interesting question because it occurred
to me the other day that nowhere does
the human being fit into all of this are
we destined just to be cancer you know
are we the Earth's cancer is that it
it's an interesting question and if we
take a little more up to this view some
people would say oh no what I mean we
may be the cancer now but actually were
destined to be the intelligence I was a
planet I love that one if we were truly
the intelligence of the pilot I doubt we
would become the cancer of the planet I
think it's more likely that we represent
a highly developed ego structure for the
planet you might say with the planetary
ego we're the sense of separate self
we're the part of the planet that can
say we are here and everything else is
out there subjectivity young and but
that's more the principle of modernity
started beyond the Renaissance and the
era of capitalism and Protestantism
right tied in with that that also at
that time the vision of the human is the
master of the earth exactly which you
have also in the Bible but the command
to go and master and conquer you have
dominion right dominion over all in the
fields of flowers etc the interesting
thing is that if we look on ourselves as
the the development of the ego structure
for planet Earth which is my personal
theory it may be that the next phase
forth since we've been caught up in
being very egotistical as a for quite a
while and manifesting that that new
exploration of what Earth herself is and
exploring that for Earth maybe the next
step is actually to join with other
really the step beyond which is where
the ego structure begins to see how yes
there is separation and
self-identification but there is also
tremendous interconnectedness also a
level of ended indivisibility
a level of which we're all in great
being again and obviously most
interestingly if we are to survive as a
species or maybe if the earth ourself is
to survive at least in the organic
richness that she now manifests we may
have to go through that transition into
valuing all the species and all of life
in the same way that we value our own
life and the life of our own species is
in other words we'll have to make that
philosophical leap and gives that same
value to other forms of life that we
give to our own if we're actually going
to survive ourselves and that's a
curious thing is you think that Homo
sapiens is the first species that is
Paris has a parasitic relationship with
Mother Earth rather than symbiotic and
is this a fatal flaw that's a hard
question to answer I mean we've had so
many of many other species that have
been here and going extinct like the
dinosaurs dinosaur species and so on
but I think we can say that there are
other systems of vast intelligence on
the planet right now I've spent a lot of
time with the whales and the Dolphins
and there's no question that those those
animals are beings of tremendous
intelligence when you think about a a
frontal brain system that we identify
with rational consciousness and
intelligence that is so much larger
investor than ours that you can put the
brain of some of those things who would
fill an entire pickup truck
compared to our brain and their
communication system is so incredibly
complex as I click that is alone as an
indication of intelligence and they're
vastly superior to us the feeling I've
often got from spending time with whales
down in Baja where I do these these
wilderness solos in some that their
intelligence is oh I guess an analogy
would be to say it's like a galactic
level awareness of course the Dolphins
the purposes are extremely intelligent
too but they're a little more
I have a feeling a little more
accessibility somehow there's a
tremendous open hardness to the whales
and the Dolphins both when they come in
when folks go out and do a wilderness
solo down there and we've been doing
this solo so that people can make a
deeper connection with nature directly
heading out by themselves any out by
themselves and basically spending seven
days after three days of doing some
awareness training together and then
they go out for seven days they're
completely alone but but it's
comfortable and they stay completely
present working with their senses to
connect deeply with the truth of what's
in the environment without any Theory
just experiencing and what they
experience is particularly for some of
the political and social leaders that
have gone through this process is
absolutely amazing one man went through
this recently as leader of a major
technological university publishing
house and when he came back he was his
entire view of what the world was but
did what earth is the diak quality of
earthy organic beingness of Earth and
his placement had changed and he has
started up a major ecological publishing
magazine and is going to host two major
conferences on Gaia through this
university which up until now has been
largely focused on technology and
industrial development that's the kind
of impact that a direct connection
without any particular theories with
mother earth can have if you just go
direct and that's of course the kind of
thing that the Native Americans did
through their Vision Quest and I think
it's no accident that the Native
Americans because they had the Vision
Quest were able to cultivate they would
go out at least once in a lifetime and
usually three or four times or the
medicine people would go out sometimes
once a year and because that direct
perception linked them with with levels
of truth that one can only know by going
through the experience
out of that truth came the kinds of
values we talked about the Ethel on the
last program which said we will make no
major changes in in the earth and in our
local earth unless we know that will be
beneficial to all of our children and
all beings out to the seventh generation
that's a value system that really
understands the working so the planet
and honors it so the reason we've been
doing these these wilderness solar
programs is to basically reintroduce
that kind of a process into our culture
so that we can create a different kind
of value system which will have that
kind of a organic wholeness to it and in
John what kind of practical ecological
measures come out of the gaia philosophy
to preserve our earth we talked earlier
of the pollution and depletion of the
air of the soil of the water of the
oceans what sorts of measures does this
sort of philosophical meditation lead to
to preserve these aspects of our natural
environment if you some people call this
deep ecology I prefer just to call it
the ecological view or since it's a
sacred view because you you have a
tremendously sacred feeling about life
after you go through this kind of
experience the what happens is you no
longer can view your your own life or
the life of the other beings of the
planet as something apart from you you
literally feel connected to everything
it's not that to say that you're totally
caught up in in unity but it's to say
that you feel completely interconnected
you feel the relationship with all
beings and you begin to perceive all
beings as having meaning and direct
relationship to you and you to them
again it becomes more like family now
when you begin to have a relationship
like family with all the different ends
of the earth your values shift when your
values shift then you begin to place
priority on
things like well if I build a power
plant down here or I'm going to put a
nuclear power plant over here or I'm
going to put an industry over there
that's polluting the river it's going to
kill all my brothers and sisters who
live in that river it's going to kill
part of me what I'm connected to my part
of my family the Native Americans called
the the plants and they have the
four-legged sand and the wicked people
and the stone people and they saw
everything in that way as family I feel
that this kind of a process particularly
for a widespread a basic part of our
education the wilderness solo or the
Vision Quest that it would completely
change the way in which we relate to
nature and that all of our laws all of
our the way that we create technology
would shift we would then say well
obviously we're going to have
technologies that work in harmony with
the whole fabric of life that's
important that we value that we place
that just as important as social
security Jon we only have about ten
minutes we want to talk about what needs
to be done we talked about a need to
change philosophically but the world
isn't a very philosophical place when
you talk about multinational
corporations and capitalism and banks
and social Eastern Europe and the
government's they've had their Stalinism
all just destroying the earth for power
and profits and production from the
things you've told us last time we're
facing incredible disasters we must take
enormous steps immediately I would
assume there's a lot of levels for hope
I personally feel that one of the best
things that people can do is to take
direct action in their own lives on
issues that have they have a direct
relationship with I mentioned last time
that they work that we did to stop I
measure copper smelter in
Arizona that was directly affecting
polluting the air of everyone in
southern Arizona everyone living in this
country has issues directly affecting
them in their lives today and I'm a
strong advocate of taking direct action
to to make the changes if government is
resistant to the kinds of changes that
need to be made
get together with your friends and take
a direct action go ahead and chain
yourself to a bulldozer if necessary the
main thing is when you take a direct
action and you make a statement like
that a very strong statement put your
life on the line if you do that to keep
a good compassionate heart a good
ecological warrior has a loving heart
Gandhi always honored and respected his
opponents and saw the basic humanity of
them underneath but he was a warrior at
the same time he took the courageous
action he put his life on the line where
necessary and I'm saying this because I
feel that ecological activism is on the
rise people are really fed up and
there's a danger that activism could
fall into the pit of becoming filled
with anger and hatred then we would just
be in the situation of the Lebanon or
the Middle East we have all the
factionalism and the fundamentalism and
the hatred only feeds on itself so it's
very important for activists to radiate
compassion and love to their opponents
at the same time they're taking the
action there needs to be a real
understanding this it's not easy if
you're sitting there change of a tree
and the logger is coming at you with it
with a chainsaw with hate in his eyes
but it's good practice that at another
level there are many many actions that
people can take in your everyday life
there are all kinds of shifts that you
can make to bring solar energy into your
into your home to bring recycling into
your household to bring a reduction with
a simpler lifestyle into your life if
you live more simply you'll have lower
taxes you'll have fewer worries
have fewer possessions to worry about I
I'm amazed when people go out and solo
the one thing they tell me consistently
is and what in them when I go back John
I'm going to simplify my life
tremendously because I realize for the
first time that I really don't need very
much to be happy because these people go
out with basically nothing and spend a
week was nothing and realized that
they're blissfully happy just being in
nature with nothing so why do they tie
themselves up and knots back in the
cities to support all this stuff which
is making them unhappy basically they're
suffering as a result of their stuff so
lonely sexist you you simplify your
stuff and you boil it down to a more
centralized form of living that's that's
in harmony with nature and reduce your
consumption if we can reduce our
consumption we could dramatically reduce
our impact on the environment the United
States is consuming probably close to
half the world's resources we have what
5% of the world's population I've seen
estimates as high as 60 percent of the
world's resources Jim what about on the
sort of national and even global level
these environmental problems are global
the air the water the earth all of these
ecological systems are interconnected so
what can people do to stop pollution on
a more national level well one of the
things that I've been doing give you
another practical example there there
are some very good organizations doing
important work Rainforest Action Network
San Francisco is an excellent group
working on the tropical forest issues
our threshold foundation has something
called the environmental crisis fund at
the philosophy behind that is to
basically have people tie the portion of
their they'll say their salary their
gross salary and then that salary and
maybe five percent of their gross salary
goes directly into environmental crises
where a small amount of money can have a
powerful impact usually if you're trying
to get a grant for a project you're at
you may sit back and
try to get that money for a year if
you're going through a federal agency or
a major foundation very often rainforest
is lost before you can raise the money
to do it about it so we thought it was
important to have a fund that can I
could immediately provide cash
immediately to help support flying for
example a rainforest person perhaps in a
tribal elder from the rainforest to
testify before a congressional hearing
in Congress maybe an appropriations
committee meeting that was that's that's
being called on whether or not to give a
big hunk of money to the World Bank to
build a dam that will flood the
rainforest where that man lives and it
has to be done within a week so you can
put your own energy your work and your
help towards those kinds of outfits and
you can certainly help them through your
through your financing I think it's very
appropriate to tithe yourself and help
out the environmental organizations that
are doing such hard work today when you
look at the amount of money going into
all of the other often very socially
questionable causes and you look at the
poverty of the environmental movement I
think it's about time we at least tide
ourselves five or ten percent for the
earth and is there enough of an
environmental movement to save the
environment at this stage in history
it's building I don't think we're
anywhere close to having a sufficiently
powerful movement to to solve what's
ahead of us that's why I'm saying we
have to really get to work we don't have
the power the people have the power the
ones who are benefiting on the short
term from exploiting the earth and
destroying it are these people getting
increased sense of consciousness
consciousness in a few cases perhaps but
there's a tendency for folks that handle
to have a lot of power to hold on to
their power at any cost
and uh my own feeling is that at this
point in time we have to put a
tremendously strong pressure on all of
the channels of change in government
corporations government George Bush
claims he's the environmental
president earlier show you critiqued
Ronald Reagan for his disastrous
ecological policies do you see any shift
in Bush or is this just rhetoric
I think Bush is a much more enjoyed
politician and he basically reads the
currents of and the winds of change says
the right thing and then does what he
really wants to do hind the scenes just
to develop what's a wide for example I
saw in the paper today that yesterday he
made a big pronouncement about how
wonderful Earth Day was the next day
what did the Interior Department do it
went out and announced that it was
opening up a whole new spectrum of oil
leasing opportunities along our coasts I
mean what does that tell you judge the
man by his actions not by his words what
would you be your final message to the
American people out there place the
environment first in your life at least
for the next 20 years make that number
one and put your energy a good hunk of
your time and tide yourself some of your
your money your income to put directly
towards turning things around and come
in the creation of ecologically
sustainable society and not just helping
your own immediate life in your
neighborhood and your town and your
County in your state a region in your
bio region but also putting something
into helping the global issues of
tropical deforestation the true this
destruction of the oceans which is upon
us I mean we're just beginning to
address the tremendous loss of the
oxygen producing plankton that we have
in the oceans we're seeing the need for
having all of our fleets of oil tankers
I think triple hulls not just double
hulled and we need to do something about
the unbelievable overfishing